y
la unión europea' tilda de chantaje la
medida rusa de suspender el suministro
de gas a polonia bulgaria por no acceder
a cambiar el sistema de pagos en rublos
el bloque trabaja en una respuesta
conjunta para minimizar el impacto en
los consumidores y culminar con la
dependencia de los combustibles rusos
la respuesta al líder de mianmar aung
san suu kyi fue condenada a 5 años de
prisión en la primera sentencia por la
decena de cargos de corrupción
presentados en su contra por la junta
militar que tomó el poder tras un golpe
de estado en febrero de 2021 y en
francia- de manuel macrón reapareció en
público después de asegurarse un nuevo
mandato presidencial en la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones del pasado 24
de abril el líder visitó un mercado en
el suburbio parisino de sergi donde
aseguró que planea cambiar las políticas
hacia la renovación
buenos días bienvenidos a una nueva
misión informativa de france 24 en
español gracias por seguir
acompañándonos como cada día soy
santiago ariztía comenzamos esta emisión
con información sobre la guerra en
ucrania que ya está transitando su día
número 63 la unión europea demostró su
apoyo a los países del bloque en su
negativa a ceder al que denominan un
chantaje del gas del kremlin es que el
suministro de gas ruso les fue cortado a
polonia y también a bulgaria que no
accedieron a cambiar el sistema de pagos
en rublos una decisión de moscú en
represalia por las sanciones dadas por
la guerra en ucrania los líderes del
viejo continente están dispuestos a
culminar con la dependencia de los
combustibles fósiles rusos marina
sardinia con todos los detalles
rusia desafió a occidente a través del
gigante del gas ruso gazprom
moscú cumplió su amenaza de interrumpir
el suministro de combustible a polonia y
bulgaria lo hizo ante la negativa de
estas naciones a pagar en rublos como
exigió el kremlin inspirar a tu gas gas
con la suspensión del gas de gazprom es
una flagrante violación de su contrato
en un chantaje al utilizar un plan
contractual de pago en rublos a través
de terceros que no garantizan los
suministros ni el dinero de los búlgaros
en respuesta a polonia dijo este martes
que intentará imponer multas
contractuales a rusia
26 gigas no vamos a pagar en rublos por
el gas ruso hacemos un llamado a todos
nuestros socios en la unión europea no
sólo para que no paguen por el gas ruso
primero para crear un mecanismo aduanero
especial para el gas y petróleo
provenientes de rusia para que rusia no
pueda adquirir fácilmente otros
mecanismos en segundo lugar apelamos a
introducir las llamadas sanciones
secundarias frost expulsión positiva de
gran cove y podría haber nuevos estas
semanas antes de turno los líderes
europeos cerraron filas alegando que no
cederán al chantaje del gas
europa y alemania pagarán en euros
algunos países pueden hacerlo en dólares
pero no en rublos
la presidenta de la comisión europea
señaló su intención de culminar la
dependencia de los combustibles fósiles
rusos
waller kremlin fracasó una vez más en su
intento de sembrar división entre los
estados miembros la era de los
combustibles fósiles rusos está llegando
a su fin en europa
europa avanza en temas energéticos works
on energy jesús el portavoz del kremlin
por su parte amenaza con más cortes a
futuro y culpa a las naciones europeas
de medidas inamistosas contra su país
por las sanciones contra personas y
empresas de rusia y el apoyo a kiev en
la guerra de ucrania
la necesidad de esta nueva metodología
fue provocada por aquellas medidas sin
amistosas sin precedentes en la economía
y los sectores financieros que fueron
tomadas por naciones inamistosas hacia
nosotros la dependencia del gas ruso
supera 50 por ciento en 14 países del
bloque europeo y rusia es el proveedor
de una veintena de naciones por lo que
en el seno de europa preocupa que si
gazprom lleva a cabo sus amenazas se
desate una crisis económica
mientras tanto el presidente ruso
vladimir putin advirtió que cualquier
país que intente interferir en ucrania
enfrentará una respuesta rápida como un
rayo y aseguró que ya tomó todas las
decisiones sobre cómo reaccionaría moscú
ante esa situación dirigiéndose a los
legisladores en sant petersburgo repitió
que occidente busca dividir a rusia y lo
acusó de empujar al gobierno de quien al
conflicto respecto del rublo ruso afirmó
que resiste las sanciones y prometió más
acciones a los intentos de aislamiento
tras efectuar la suspensión de
suministro de gas a polonia y a bulgaria
bloqueamos el primer golpe aplastante
como lo creían en occidente des acciones
ilegítimas contra nuestro país nuestro
sistema bancario la moneda nacional el
transporte el comercio la economía en su
conjunto las han resistido y no se han
derrumbado al contrario ahora tenemos
una buena razón para el desarrollo
y tal como decíamos europa reacciona y
se prepara para dejar de depender de los
combustibles rusos pero ya comienzan a
surgir discrepancias entre los países en
torno a este tema ampliamos desde
bruselas con nuestra corresponsal esther
herrera
pues ahora es que no sabemos qué es lo
que puede ocurrir se rusia también
tomará medidas frente a otros países
europeos y también les cortará el gas de
momento hungría ha asegurado que el gas
sigue fluyendo en su caso porque llegó a
un acuerdo en que podría pagar en euros
y así luego poderlo convertir en rublos
los pagos del gas pero la decisión ahora
mismo podría redoblar la presión a las
capitales europeas que actualmente están
negociando un posible embargo del
petróleo y del gas pero es una cuestión
muy divisiva hay países como por ejemplo
precisamente hungría que lo están
evitando que están bloqueando esta
decisión pero no es casualidad que rusia
haya tomado esta decisión sabe que es
una cuestión muy decisiva y podría
dividir muchísimo más a los países que
hasta ahora ha mostrado una gran unidad
frente a las sanciones frente a las
sanciones contra rusia hay que tener en
cuenta que aún así la comisión europea
propuso reducir dos tercios este mismo
año la dependencia del gas ruso pérez no
será nada fácil y como ya se comentaba
la inflación puede subir y también los
precios
y en la garra de ucrania la muerte de
los soldados es objeto de controversias
y es que según moscú unos 1.350
militares están fallecidos desde el
inicio de la invasión mientras que
ucrania sostienen que la cifra es más
alta todavía y descubrir la verdad sin
embargo no es una tarea fácil implica
costosos análisis e irene sabio y
leticia álvarez enviadas especiales de
france 24 nos traen la historia
en tiempos normales en este cementerio
no se verían tumbas esperando ataúdes o
sepulturas sin identificar pero aquí
están esta es la realidad en la parte
nueva del cementerio militar de crans no
pil iba de mí pero desde que comenzó la
guerra en ucrania
varios días a la semana a mikael y 5
vicealcalde de ni pero recibe
información de las morgues donde se
acumulan los cuerpos de los soldados
muertos en la guerra pero algunos
cuerpos no son fáciles de identificar
les tomamos el adn y cuando las familias
nos lo piden lo comparamos
para determinar de dónde es el soldado y
quiénes son sus allegados
pese a que aún hoy no hay
investigaciones independientes que lo
corroboren lysenko dice que también hay
cuerpos de soldados rusos muertos en
localidades como tones jarquín y lugansk
nos lleva hasta el camión frigorífico
donde nos han colocado y permite que los
veamos pero no que lograremos
estas informaciones no pueden ser
difundidas en base a las leyes
ucranianas y has visto que en las bolsas
con los nombres y apellidos no queremos
hacer daño a sus parientes y que se
enteren de su muerte a través de un
reportaje
ni la muerte tiene tregua y por su parte
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson aseguró este miércoles que los
más de 200 legisladores de la cámara de
los comunes que fueron sancionados por
rusia deberían ver esta medida como una
insignia de honor y de esta manera a
johnson respondió al anuncio del
ministerio de relaciones exteriores de
rusia que aplicó sanciones a
287 miembros del parlamento de reino
unido incluido el presidente de la
cámara como represalia a la decisión
británica de sancionar a 368 miembros de
la cámara de diputados rusa
todos esos 287 deberían considerarlo
como una insignia de honor y lo que
nosotros lo que nosotros haremos señor
presidente es mantener nuestro apoyo
firme y de principios al pueblo
ucraniano y su derecho a proteger sus
vidas sus familias y defenderse perham
es entender eso cambiamos el tema y
vamos ahora hasta mí al mar donde la
líder de respuesta y premio nobel de paz
aún san suu kyi fue condenada a 5 años
de prisión por corrupción se trata de
uno de los 18 cargos presentados en su
contra en un juicio que se realiza a
puerta cerrada en este país que está
controlado por la junta militar vamos
con el informe
de liderar el estado a enfrentarse a los
tribunales 14 meses después de que la
obligaron a dejar el poder aún san suu
syi fue declarada culpable
el último cargo más de 11 kilos de oro y
600 mil dólares que presuntamente aceptó
como soborno de un colega el ex primer
ministro de la ciudad de rangún una
sentencia de prisión de cinco años que
se suma a las otras dos condenas que
recibió hace solo unos meses por burlar
las reglas de covite e importar walkie
talkies lo que supone que la ascendencia
suman 11 años hasta el momento los
juicios han sido rechazados por algunos
sectores de la comunidad internacional y
la propia sushi calificó previamente la
acusación de absurda
pero la junta militar que le quitó el
poder el año pasado dice que el juicio
está a cargo de un poder judicial
independiente y está permitiendo que la
mujer de 76 años cumpla su condena bajo
arresto domiciliario en un lugar no
revelado
susi pasó 15 años bajo arresto
domiciliario por liderar una lucha no
violenta por la democracia por la que
ganó el premio nobel de la paz en 1991
en total los 18 cargos en su contra
conllevan a una pena de cárcel máxima
combinada de casi 190 años
y pese a las críticas por parte de la
comunidad internacional en singapur fue
ejecutado un hombre con discapacidad
intelectual la unión europea pidió este
miércoles a singapur que acabe con la
pena de muerte de tras la ejecución de
nagaa entré andar mal y ganó un preso
malasio de 34 años que había sido
condenado por narcotráfico el tribunal
rechazó la apelación final que presentó
la madre alegando la discapacidad de su
hijo quien pasó más de una década en el
corredor de la muerte tras su arresto en
abril de 2009 por introducir
42.72 gramos de heroína en este país que
tiene una de las leyes anti drogas más
duras de todo el mundo
un nuevo episodio en las tensiones entre
francia y malí el gobierno de transición
de malí acusó al ejército galo de
espionaje luego de que éste publicara
recientemente unas imágenes grabadas con
un dron que muestran a supuestos
mercenarios rusos enterrando cadáveres
cerca de una base en el centro del país
en un comunicado del gobierno dirigido
por la junta militar que tomó el poder
mediante un golpe de estado denunció
vuelos de drones del ejército francés
que se dedican a actividades
consideradas como de espionaje de
intimidación y de subversión
vamos con más noticias el reelecto
presidente de francia hablamos por
supuesto de manuel macro no reapareció
en público luego de haberse asegurado un
nuevo mandato tras su victoria en la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones del
pasado 24 de abril incitó a un mercado
en el suburbio parisino desde el gym
donde tuvo un amplio respaldo en el
ballottage una multitud acudió al
mercado donde fue recibido por
simpatizantes y también por detractores
que le arrojaron tomates durante su
recorrido el mandatario dijo que planea
cambiar las políticas que tienden a
ubicar a los pobres en barrios que ya
son pobres un aspecto que admitió que no
pudo cambiar en su primer mandato
presidencial
pero que lo que todos sentimos es que
hay una demanda renovada hacia los
servidores y hacia los que van a tener
que gobernar y legislar
en los barrios más pobres sean de la
ciudad o del campo hay que recrear las
condiciones reales y efectivas de
igualdad
y países bajos se vistió de naranja y lo
hizo para celebrar un esperado día del
rey y es que la fiesta que se aplazó dos
veces por la pandemia de coronavirus
emociona nuevamente a los ciudadanos con
una normalidad que por fin se siente en
las calles y no lo cuenta nuestra
corresponsal el mar y ángulo
7 de abril
tiene un color naranja la razón es la
conmemoración del llamado con estar o
día del reino que se celebra en el reino
de los países bajos en honor al
cumpleaños del rey willem alexander en
esta oportunidad luego de haber sido
cancelado 22 veces por la pandemia no
hay recepciones como el uso obligatorio
de tapabocas ni tampoco distanciamiento
social se lleva a cabo el evento central
aquí
centrales de más clic la ciudad ubicada
en el sur de los países bajos y que es
reconocida por su arquitectura medieval
escuchamos es de fondos tonadas nórdicas
tradicionales como parte de la muestra
musical adelantada para darle la
bienvenida al rey pero aunque en los
últimos ocho años esta tradición se ha
llevado a cabo en este día de abril
desde 2014 la realidad es que la idea de
ahorrar el natalicio del monarca de
turno data desde el año
1885 en el que homenaje a la entonces
princesa y posterior reina willemijn a
fue designado el 31 de agosto para
celebrar una festividad tan nacional en
esta fecha todos se reúnen en torno a la
familia y los amigos y brinda a la salud
del reino
es todo por el momento pero en breve
regresamos con muchas más noticias así
que sigan informados en el resto de
nuestra programación y también por
supuesto en france24 punto com sigan con
nosotros
[Música]